[Music]
hey minimizers you're getting ready to
watch some footage from one of the
minimalist live events if you'd like to
see us on the road head on over to
theminimalists.com to find a city near
you or you can watch recordings of all
of our live events over at patreon.com
the minimalists enjoy
howdy hi i'm scared to ask you my
question now often
what's your name or your alias my name
is stacey
stacy yeah hey stacy what's on your mind
so in a recent podcast you had someone
text in and ask about a roommate
situation
and you guys had talked about i think a
previous
roommate situation as well i think maybe
it was you who ended up leaving yeah i
did not choose my roommates wisely
melbourne did so
i have a roommate situation but it's
it's my daughter
so i can't leave
and i can't ask her to leave she's young
yeah um but she is a hoarder
and the horde
spills if i say nothing about the horde
in her space
it makes me uncomfortable to know what's
there but that's her space but it's like
spilling out into my space and
it's not just the things but
i'm a single parent i work really hard
and
it's my energy and time that goes in
having to like manage her stuff in my
space that
i think upsets me more than the stuff so
what do you do
when the people you love love their
things more than they love you
stacy um wow i know it's not true it
feels that way sometimes no no no yeah
it
if it feels that way then it is there is
a truth in it
right now
your daughter how old is she she's 19
and she has a 21 month old son and they
both live with me okay
wow
well as long as they live with you which
by the way she has the capability of
leaving
um but as long as she lives with you
then she's going to operate under your
boundaries
my daughter's eight and she operates
under our boundaries as well um and
now we don't set a bunch of arbitrary
boundaries to frustrate her or make her
upset it doesn't sound like that's where
you are either right we're not talking
about you know organizing a garage here
oh she's she's taken over the garage too
with her stuff i can't even park my car
in the garage anymore yeah it's that bad
you and 34 of americans um
so
um i will say this if she's if she's a
hoarder and you feel like that there's
it's undiagnosed and and she needs some
psychological help it is a mental
disorder
um
and so
understanding that i think also helps
gives us some compassion right she it
feels like she loves her things
but she's confused about what love
actually is
i made a joke early on when i was doing
the reading like oh yeah i would i love
my wife but i also love burritos right
well one of those things is extreme
like oh i really like burritos now your
daughter really likes her stuff
and so
i maybe talked to her about why she
really likes her stuff so much why is
she more compelled by her stuff
than by anything else
because if there is something more
compelling that's in front of her the
stuff becomes so less interesting
so quickly
oh i think that's tweetable maybe
uh like the pithy thing that comes to
mind is um
to set boundaries is to love
and that's good we we sometimes to
expound on that we sometimes think that
the loving thing to do is just
constantly say yes
it's actually very unloving because
you're damaging yourself when you do
that
um
so
when you tell someone no you can set you
can explain it what you're actually
saying yes too because anytime you say
no you're saying yes to something else
and helping her see what you're saying
yes to will really help but i
i totally agree with what milburn said
maybe that boundary is hey um
i can see you're attached to your stuff
and as your mom i you know i don't want
to like just force you into getting rid
of your stuff but there's obviously some
sort of
underlying
discontent or something that's happening
and i would really like to bring in a
third party to like help us figure out
what's going on because
i love you and i want you to live here
but living here in these conditions it's
really damaging our relationship it's
damaging my relationship with my
grandchild
and and she doesn't want that of course
and like you said you know she loves you
way more than she loves her stuff but it
does feel
it feels the opposite
um
so yeah i mean maybe that's a boundary
set up but it does sound like
you know maybe if bringing in a
professional bringing a third party i'm
not talking about an organizer
i'm talking about like someone who can
get to the root of the why
the root of the desires therapists
well yeah i mean maybe not a hoarder's
therapist specifically but um i mean but
yeah maybe some type of therapist i
don't know you know if she would be open
to that but you can approach that in a
way like again like
to set boundaries is to love
just i think i'm i have done that and i
see ways where i can do it better i
think what's frustrating for me is
it is impacting our relationship it's
impacting my ability to enjoy the fact
that i get my daughter and my grandson
in my house
because i know that's a really special
thing especially in modern society where
we don't live in multi-generational
houses anymore so i really want to be
able to enjoy them there and have them
there but all i see is there's stuff
everywhere and it's i know that's a me
thing right and plus a boundary thing
with her but i just want to enjoy having
them there because it's not going to
last forever
yeah yeah the
the
[Music]
helping her doesn't mean doing it for
her
and i think quite often we can confuse
the two you know i remember with with my
daughter like well we'll just i'll clean
her room for her so it's up to my
standards
right and i have ocd so like
i'm in there organizing her toy bins and
here's how it should be and
and she's like yeah whatever um
and
and and so we confused doing something
for someone
but not realizing oh wait a minute this
is actually
this is accomplishing the opposite this
is making them dependent
on on me
and it's not actually showing them
the way
but you can show her the way
and
it's going to take some time it's going
to take some compassion it's going to
take some understanding from both of you
and it may even take a little bit of
compromise after you've set up those
boundaries but i'll tell you this the
reason the boundaries haven't stuck so
far is because you haven't stuck to them
anytime the boundaries don't stick it's
because i refuse to stick to my own
boundaries i'll just compromise a little
bit here i take off every other
wednesday to spend with my wife and
inevitably all like i'm just gonna work
for two hours this morning real quick
before she wakes up and then it devolves
into all these other things because
other people then start calling me
because they didn't realize i'm taking
the day off because i've already sent
out 15 emails in the morning
and so they didn't respect my boundaries
because i didn't respect my boundaries
i've been ignoring the boundary and just
ignoring the conversation altogether
lately because i just haven't gotten
anywhere in the past so i think it's
time to revisit
another pit the answer that came to mind
is uh
when you lead with compassion you can
it's possible to have any conversation
so
when you're approaching her
if you start to get
upset angry any negative emotions like
like have the context of compassion to
like bring yourself back to like no like
i need to approach this in a
compassionate way and you may have you
may try to have that conversation once
and you might have to walk away from it
and then you might have to come back but
if you're leading with compassion you
can talk about anything so don't give up
is what you're saying yeah don't give up
thanks for your sincere questions
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free